A farm supply store carries four
different brands of pesticide.
Each brand sells pesticide
of a different concentration.
And each brand also has a
different size of bottle.
So here we have the
different brands,
they give us the bottle
size, the concentration,
so that's the percentage of this
fluid volume that is actually
pesticide that's actually
active ingredient.
And then they tell us
the price per bottle.
And they ask us if we want
the most active ingredient
for our money, you
should spend your money
on bottles of brand
question mark.
So let's just think about
which of these brands
gives us the most active
ingredient for our money.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and try to think about
this on your own.
Well, let's just think
about active ingredient.
I'll just write
ingred for short.
Ingredient per bottle.
And I'll do this in milliliters.
So, we have 375 milliliters, 65%
of which is going to be active.
So 65% of 375 gets
us 243.75 milliliters
of active ingredient per bottle.
How much is that active
ingredient per dollar here?
Well, you could just
reason through it.
You say I have
273.75 mLs for $22.
So if I want per dollar,
I'll just divide this by 22.
So let me see.
If I just do that as
my previous answer,
which is that divided
by 22, and I'll just
round to the nearest
penny, $11.08.
Let me see.
This is in mLs.
11.07.
Once again, this is
in mLs, not dollars.
This is mLs per bottle,
milliliters per bottle,
divided by $22 per bottle,
gets us 11.07 mLs per dollar.
Actually, let me
write it that way.
mLs per dollar, just so we
can keep track of the unit.
This is mLs per bottle.
Now another way that we could
have thought about it is look.
You have 273.75 mLs per bottle.
We want to get it
to mLs per dollar.
So we want to get rid of a
bottle in the denominator.
So we would want to
multiply it by something
with bottles in the numerator.
And we want to introduce a
dollar in the denominator,
so it would be
bottles per dollar.
And how many bottles
are there per dollar?
Or another way to think about
it is one bottle is $22.
So you multiply 23.75 times 1
over 22, you would get 11.07.
And that cancels with that,
milliliters per dollar.
And notice, you could have
done this through common sense.
This is equivalent
to just dividing.
This is how much you get for
a $22 bottle, divided by $22,
you get the
milliliters per dollar.
But either way, let's do
it for the rest of them.
So for this one right over here,
in general, to figure this out,
we just have to multiply the
concentration times the bottle
size.
And then divide it by the price.
So let's just do that
for the next three.
So the concentration is 35%.
So 0.35 times 750.
So this expression
is going to give us
the milliliters of
active ingredient.
And then we can divide
by the cost per bottle.
So this is 12.5
milliliters per dollar.
Now this next one,
they give us one liter.
But we know one liter is
equal to 1,000 milliliters.
75% of that is going to
be active ingredient,
so we're going to
have 750 milliliters
of active ingredient.
And it's going to cost $68.
So we just divide this by 68.
And we get 750
milliliters divided by 68,
it gets us $11, and
if we round, $0.3.
We're in milliliters.
11.03 milliliters per dollar.
Have to be very careful.
This is milliliters per dollar.
That's the whole point of this
is to keep track of the units.
So this isn't dollars, this
is milliliters per dollar.
And then finally, 1.5 liters.
We'll times 1,000
milliliters per liter.
This would give us
1,500 milliliters,
30% of which is active.
So 30% of 1,500 milliliters.
That's 450 milliliters.
And then we can
divide that by $40.
So 450 divided by $40 gets us
to 11.25 milliliters per dollar.
So which one is the best deal?
Well, the best deal
is the one where
I get the most
milliliters per dollar.
And that's brand
b right over here.
I get 12.5 milliliters
per dollar.
I'm getting the most
pesticide for my buck.